hello everyone welcome to a nanostring
sponsored labyrinths presentation for
neuroscience 2021
i will be the moderator for the session
my name is elizabeth schneider i'm a
senior global marketing manager here at
nanastring today we have the pleasure of
speaking
dr francis edwards she's a professor of
neurodegeneration in the department of
neuroscience physiology and pharmacology
at university college london and today
we'll be she will be speaking about
using the nanostring geomics digital
spatial profiler to look at gene
expression in microglia and astrocytes
in relation to plaque
dr edwards is a cns synaptic
physiologist
she graduated with a bachelor's degree
in behavioral
pharmacology from the university of
sydney in her native australia also had
a master's degree there as well she
moved on to electrophysiology gaining
her phd
between the australian national
university and the max planck institute
for biophysical chemistry
and her current lab
specializes um in electrophysiology but
also adds on gene expression
immunohistochemistry
and molecular techniques and a primary
aim is to improve mass models of
alzheimer's disease by investigating the
role of different alzheimer's disease
risk factors in knock-in mice with
alzheimer's mutation
so thanks everyone for joining and thank
you dr edwards we're looking forward to
your presentation
thank you very much for that nice
introduction
so we have just recently um discovered
the nanostring technology and it's
really i think brought up some very
interesting new things that we can look
at in so starting with genes that we
sort of knew something about but then
bringing in both cell specific and
regional specific information and this
makes a uh a really very big difference
to how we're going to
um alison van schoeck is the person at
nanostring who's been incredibly helpful
and um has has
done a lot of the uh
has done all the sort of technical side
of getting the data and jack wood and
eugenia wong are students in my lab
who've done a lot of the processing of
the data that i'll talk about today
um and we are funded by cure alzheimer's
fund and alzheimer's research uk and
this is all done in collaboration with
john hardy as well
so we work on alzheimer's disease just a
very brief introduction i think most
people have some idea about alzheimer's
disease and its devastating effects on
cognition
um basically it starts with the
deposition of extracellular plaques
which are the ringed in circles in this
tissue here
they come they're in the extracellular
tissue and they build up over decades
before any diagnosis occurs
sometime sometime again
several years before the diagnosis is
likely to occur the tower tangles start
to build up and these are now the ones
that are in the triangles here and
they're inside the neurons in the brain
and it's only once these tangles start
to build up that you notice a massive
loss of synapses and brain tissue and
you see on the right there the
horrendous effect of alzheimer's
disease on the brain by the time the
person eventually dies often five or ten
years later
so that's a that's a a very great effect
but it takes years before you know that
you actually have this disease building
up and there's no treatment at the
moment that um can slow or reverse the
progress of this disease there are some
some helpful um treatments for
for some of the symptoms and there has
just recently been been now released a
drug which mops up amyloid beta so it'll
be interesting to see how that goes but
this is a very something that needs a
lot more information so that's just the
background of the sort of thing that
we're looking at and we're trying to
understand how that disease progresses
from amyloid beta plaques through to tau
tangles and onwards
another feature of the disease which has
become clear over the last few years is
the microglia and the innate immune
system of the brain are very closely
involved somehow in the progression of
this disease
we showed quite a few years ago now in
2015 that there's a 0.97
correlation between
certain a certain um module of
microglial gene expression and the build
up of amyloid plaques i mean that's the
highest correlation i've ever seen
anywhere i think in physiology
as well as that g well in g wave studies
it's become clear that the risk factor
genes the genes that the the variants of
genes that increase the risk of being
diagnosed with alzheimer's disease are
very often genes that are very highly
expressed in microglia
so it seems clear that that's there's
something very important about the
interaction of microglia plaques and
synapses and so forth and that's what we
have ended up working on now in various
different ways
just very briefly to introduce the
nanostring technology of course any
questions about this should go to the
people at nana's string rather than to
me he'll be able to explain much better
detail this is from a post that they
showed me when they first introduced the
technique to me a little um quite
recently
so this they have a
proprietary reagents which label all the
rna in the tissue so you have sections
very thin sections which get labeled
with these um these oligo-labeled
antibodies
so they label all the rna in your
section and then they're able to
photocleave from those from those
labels effectively a barcode so by
cutting off the dna oligo they're able
to
collect those into a tube and you can
see the sort of the step-by-step method
across on the right where the section
gets stained with these oligo's
conjugated antibodies
uh they're also stained with antibodies
to show what regions you want to be
collecting from so for example we have
stained microglia or astrocytes with
antibodies and they're able then just to
cleave the rna that are in those areas
of interest that you have labeled on the
section
they then take those into a counter and
can count the number of any particular
the number of barcodes that they have
for each of the genes that are
expressing in your section
so that's the sort of basic concept of
the um of the nano strings and i think
it becomes the mana string technology
and i think it becomes uh even clearer
when you see what our experiment is
so the idea of the experiment
is to assess the effect of the vicinity
to the plaque on gene expression so as i
said we've shown already that microglia
of genes are expressed or that a bunch
of microbial genes expressed in
incredibly close correlation with the
buildup of plaques so we want to know
whether it's just that they're only
expressed when they're near the plaque
or whether they're expressed generally
in the tissue and exactly how those
how those genes interact with the plaque
we've mostly worked on microglia but now
we're starting to work a lot on
astrocytes as well the other sort of
another sort of immune cell in the brain
and so what we've done here is looked
specifically at the gene expression in
microglia or the gene expression in
astrocytes and we've looked compared to
where they are sitting in relation to
plaques now i should say at this point
that it's important to make clear that
you're not actually doing single cell
rna-seq effectively you're not actually
collecting
just from microglia it's going to be
highly enriched for microglia but what
it's doing is you label the microglial
cell and then it cleaves
in that place where that label is so if
anything is just below or just above it
will collect that rna also extremely
enriched for the cells because the
sections are only eight microns thick
and that's pretty much the thickness of
a single cell so they're very highly
enriched for microglia or very highly in
which for alzheimer's sorry for
astrocytes excuse me um in our in our
study
so we're looking at different mouse
models we have wild-type mice the
ordinary mice we have mice that are
expressing the trem to r47h mutation
which is a microglial gene and this
particular variant of the gene
is a very strong risk factor for being
diagnosed with alzheimer's disease
unfortunately mice it also decreases the
trend to expression somewhat but so you
could say that they are trimmed to
incompetent these mice
um we then have app knock-in mice these
are mice that have a mutation have two
mutations in their app and app is the
precursor for the amyloid beta that
builds up and starts the whole plaque
deposition
so those mice start to get plaques from
about nine months of age it's not a very
aggressive model unlike some models
where they get their plaques very early
and get all sorts of um all sorts of
phenotypes these mice get their plaques
only at about nine months and it
continues gradually to express more and
more or to lay down more and more plaque
as the mice get old we consider this
very important because aging of course
is a major part of alzheimer's disease
it is generally a disease of old age and
so we think it's very important to use
truly aged mice so the mice we're using
here are 18 months and we also use my
throat up to 24 months of age
it's very common in alzheimer's studies
to see mice of 12 months being referred
to as aged mice but actually mice live
for two two and a half even
years or even a little bit more than
that and so really a 12 month old mouse
is probably the equivalent of a 35 year
old or something of that sort
so we use 18 to 24 month old mice
largely and particularly in this study
and so we um
think that this is truly aged mice
we then have mice where we have crossed
the app knock in mice with the trim to
r47h knock in mice and so these we can
then have a look at how this risk factor
affects both the plaques and how they
develop what happens to the the uh
microglia and what their phenotype is
and indeed the astrocytes
and so that this is the idea is both to
see what happens in terms of the plaques
but also to see how the trim to 47h
mutation
affects this
this is a this was just a trial study
using the tap program at um at
nanostring so this is just a very first
trial we're going to repeat this and
increase the numbers
so what we had in the first instance was
three wild-type mice three trim two mice
so they're the mice that don't have
plaques and then we had four each of the
plaque bearing mice the nlf and the nlf
trim two
so these uh unfortunately in the in the
process we lost the the information from
two of the mice so we ended up with two
three three four three as our sample
size a total of 14 mice a total of 12
giving us information
this is quite a small sample size we're
very keen to increase this but it is
remarkable how much information we've
already got even from this small sample
size
now how the system works is that you
have a slide like this this is a
standard sized slide
and you see that there's an area there
marked out 36.2 by 14.6 millimeters
and your sections have to fit within
that area
how the analysis is costed when you're
working with the tap program and it
varies depending on how you're doing
this but when you're working with the
nanostringstat program how this
works is that you
pay per slide
and each slide comes with 12 regions of
interest or areas of interest
and you can then pay for extra areas of
interest in lots of 12.
so
you can however fit as many sections as
you like on a slide or as you can
reasonably fit within that area of 36.2
by 14.6 millimeters
we managed to fit the 14 sections so one
section from each of those 14 mice onto
two slides so we had one slide with
eight that did
the schematic on the top of that and one
slide with six
sections and as you can see we have a
mixture of the genotypes on each of the
slides to try and avoid any batch
effects and so forth
on those slides we there the slides then
look like this basically so this is a
picture of the slide number one there
with the eight sections you can see on
the left hand side to pick the actual
literal picture of the slide
and then we blow up one of those
sections there in the middle to show you
what it looks like
so the first step is that you get these
you you make these eight micron sections
and you put them on a slide and you send
those off to nano string if you're doing
it by the tap technology of course um
ideally we end up with a gmx machine at
ucl and we can do all of this ourselves
but at the moment this is the situation
so we sent those off to alison and i'm
sure and
and she um
she then did all the labeling from then
on
so she then labeled those with the uh
with the proprietary probes as well as
with the antibodies for which are listed
up there on the top left um gfap for
astrocytes
team m119 for the microglia and she also
used labeled beta amyloid and um used
dappy just to label the cell body so
that you could see your way around the
slice
so you can see it in the middle there
and then blown up a little bit on the
right but it's even clearer here in the
next slide i think
so this is just where she's selected the
regions of interest they're actually
just briefly going back there um you can
see on the whole section out of that
section those little white areas are the
regions of interest and we did that
together with alison
for every single one of those sections
over zoom um over starting at sort of
six o'clock at night uk time and going
through to about midnight um we selected
section
they're regions of interest on each of
those slides now it's important to
understand the difference between the
region of interest in the area of
interest so these are the regions of
interest and the regions of interest
that we wanted to have were things that
were related to plaques and things that
were not related to plaques
so you can see now on the next slide
the one labeled a the plaques have
turquoise and those um that's completely
full of plaques there's plaques
everywhere in that section if you look
closely even where you can't really see
pla see the big plaques there are little
plaques all over the place there so all
the cells in that region are going to be
very close to plaques
the sections labeled b
don't have any plaques in them so that's
going to be well away from the plaque
so in our mice that have plaques we had
section we had regions of interest that
were a
with clarks and b without plaques
we then chose our areas of interest and
our areas of interest were those that
were labeled both with plaque and with
microglia so where the t mem119 actually
overlapped the beta amyloid antibody so
that's looking at microglia that are
actually touching plaques
and then we also looked at plaques that
the other plaques in the area sorry
excuse me the other microglia that are
in the area a
so in other words we had microglia that
were actually touching plaques and
microglia that were near plaques but not
actually touching plaques
and then we had microglia that were in
region one of the regions b
we then
did the same with astrocytes in the case
of astrocytes we didn't try and do the
ones that were touching plaques
astrocytes have very long processes and
they'll be labeled by the t-mem and it
just simply means that you wouldn't know
whether they were really touching the
plaque or whether you would likely to be
getting rna from an astrocyte that was
really interacting with a plaque or not
it's a much more complicated structure
and so we used astrocytes that were near
plaques and astrocytes that were far
from plaques in other words any
astrocyte that was in a
or any estrocyte that was in b
so those were our areas of interest
three different sorts of area of
interest for the team m119 and two
different sorts for the gfap
now then area of interest it's important
to make clear is not just one selection
it is anything within a for example that
where we had the
t-mem overlapping the plaque would count
as one area of interest for one section
in other words it's what ends up going
into one tube to be analyzed
so it's not just one little spot but
rather what goes into one tube to be
analyzed so it isn't specific to a
single cell although they are collecting
the uh the signal from single cells
from lots of single cells and they are
then pulled simply because there isn't
enough signal in a single cell so it's
all the one area of interest is all the
microglia that are touching plaques in a
or all the microbials are not touching
plugs in a
and so forth
so that was the experiment to look at
those those five different areas of
interest in cell in in animals that had
plaques and then in animals that didn't
have plaques we obviously only had far
from the equivalent of far from plaque
and we did that in an equivalent area to
a here but of course not having plaques
and that way we could be sure that we
weren't just talking about areas of the
brain that expressed different um
different levels of gene expression
this is all within the hippocampus i
might say
uh just for interest sake so on the
right we have the cells blown up a
little bit more so you can see how well
you can see the astrocytes and the
microglia and the laser comes down and
collects the data from just where you
see the green signal or where you see
the red signal so they are really quite
distinct from each other
on the left here you see another version
of our regions of interest these funny
looking shapes and i just included this
because allison is extremely careful and
goes goes to a lot of trouble to make
this work
you can see in this particular section
that we have quite a lot of blood
vessels you see there's the astrocytes
right along the blood vessels there
being labeled in green and those we
weren't interested in collecting those
they may they're likely to have a very
different function and a different gene
expression from the general astrocytes
that cluster around parts and so forth
and so she was able to bring the region
of interest right into a tiny little
channel to jump across those regions and
so avoid collecting anything from those
astrocytes even though the region of
interest itself spanned both sides of
the blood vessel so that was extremely
um helpful and so that that funny
looking shape on the right is a single
region of interest and so we could
collect everything from the microglia
within that shape
even though and it is actually
continuous even though it doesn't look
continuous from here
okay so that's how we actually collected
the data that's the data we have and
then they go off and they send it to the
counter and about a week later or so
maybe two weeks later depending on the
on the business of the system at the
time you end up getting back a big excel
excel sheet with all the tpms for each
of those regions of areas of interest
and you get the um the you get the
counts for all those areas of interest
and you get a whole lot of a whole big
software package that you can use to
deal with that data or you can just take
it from the excel sheet and and analyze
it in any way that you want yourself
they're extremely helpful they're very
helpful in helping us to get around the
software it means that somebody who's
not really a bio information can do a
lot of analysis on this data
relatively easily
so just to show you one of the things
that comes out of the software so this
is the principal components analysis and
you can see that here the red is the
astrocytes the blue and green are the
microglia and you can see there's
considerable separation between the
astrocytes and the microglia which gave
us confidence that that was really what
we were collecting
just to show you some of the data we got
out of this which i think is quite
remarkable we've done quite a lot of
rna-seq and of course that gives you a
lot of information about a lot of genes
but it doesn't tell you which cells
those genes are expressed in and it
doesn't tell you where they are
this is partly overcome by people doing
single cell rna-seq that at least gets
down to the particular cell type and
indeed the expression in a single cell
tells you what sorts of different cells
there are there but it doesn't tell you
where they are in the tissue
there are other regional things such as
as some rna scope but that will only
tell you about a few genes and not
genome-wide as we have here
here are just a few of the examples of
what we got out of this data
so here are some of the dam genes these
are the disease-associated microglia
that have been um analyzed using single
cell that have been brought out of
studies using single cell rna-seq
so looking at some of those genes that
have been related to disease-associated
microglia and here we are looking at
regional analysis
so all the graphs i'm going to show you
um
a lot of them are pretty similar if you
look at the trem2 graph there on the top
left you'll see that the left hand group
of three bars with the black outline is
the nlf mice the app nokia mice which
have plaques
the next group the grey ones are are the
ones that have nlf with the trem2
mutation
and then we have just the single columns
for the wire type mice and for the mice
with the trem2 mutation but no plaques
so those two right hand columns give you
a bit of an idea of what the background
is you're what you would expect from
background microglia where there are no
plants
in the set of three columns
for the nls or the trem2 mice the left
hand number one is always the plaque the
ones that are actually overlapping the
plaque number two is the peri plaque and
number three is the uh
is the the area that's away from the
plaque that's on the bottom of the slide
there if you're not following me well so
the left-hand column of three there is
the plaque the second is the perry
plaque and the third is the away from
player
so you can see here for example in trim
two it's quite remarkable there's a very
there's a strong relation to clark but
it is only the plaque the microglia that
are actually touching the plaque that
are showing increased expression
compared to the uh compared to the peri
plaque or the away from cloth and that's
completely prevented when you have the
trem2 mutation and as you can see the
background level isn't far it isn't very
different from what you get in the wild
type or the trem2 newton mice
it's important to note that the wild
type is only n equals 2 here so you
often see quite a big error bar you have
to be a little bit cautious about
interpreting the level of the wild type
column
these others tyro bp is rather similar
it's not quite as completely blocked by
the trem2 mutation but similarly really
only up right at the plaque
apoe is a bit different it's a bit more
sort of varied a bit more more gradually
coming down so it's up already in the
peri plaque area and it increases
further
as you get closer to the plaque it's
blunted by the trem2 mutation but not so
completely stopped
so these other ones as you can see have
various different versions of that one
there are a couple that are particularly
interesting here i think
the oh
in terms of the um
let me have a look sorry the uh the
cts l1 i think is quite interesting you
can see it gradually goes down away from
the plaque but it probably is going down
away from the plaque rather than up at
the plaque because it's going down well
below the level of the wild type and the
trim two mice
the fth1 is a ferrous and heavy chain
one that's an iron transporter
and you can see that in that case it's
down close to a plaque and up away from
the plaque
and that is in fact that it's at normal
level when it's well away from a plaque
but it's decreased as it comes in close
to a plaque and we found that very
interesting as well
it's no more decreased right at the
plaque as is at the periblack area but
when it gets anywhere near a plaque this
version gets down regulated
this is just giving you a comparison to
what you get in rna-seq so you can see
most of these genes i'm showing here
with the columns uh this this is all at
18
at 18 months from our iron ac data and
you can see there's no significant
difference when we look at rna-seq
whereas all of those genes if you
remember from previous from the previous
slide tyro b p epo in all of these
dramatically affected if you're able to
look at this in this regional and cell
specific way
this is showing trim too in a little bit
more detail in from our rna-seq data is
this is only wild type versus nlf
incidentally in this data we haven't
done the trem 2 here so this is only
wild type versus nlf in all of these
graphs
you can see we've done this from two
months old all the way through to 24
months old and trem 2 does eventually go
up
in the nlf mice fairly subtly it goes up
by about um maybe 20 percent or so
whereas in in the you saw that at the
plaque it's actually up by double
so presumably this is because we are
just watering down the data when we look
at rna-seq and the whole cell tis the
whole tissue and if it's only being
upregulated in a particular cell in a
particular area you simply won't see it
with rna-seq so even though these are
actually n equals as you see n equals 10
to 12 mice or 9 to 12 mice in these
different groups the um the
rna-seq data doesn't show any
significantly difference in most of
these
um
in most of these genes of 18 months
whereas you get with only n equals three
to four these spectacular differences
regionally using the nanostring
technology
you can also get volcano plots just to
show you more typical things that you
look at in
in
gene expression analysis of course in
this particular particular data sets we
can compare a lot of different things
in this case what i'm comparing is
the actual plaque data to just the
periplex data so not even the away from
plaque so it's just comparing the
microglia that are actually touching
plaques to the microglia that are very
close to plaques but not actually
touching them and you can see on the
left in the nlf mice there are quite a
lot of genes which above the li above
the horizontal line there is means that
they're significantly different um
statistically uh in adjusted p values
and the vertical line show you um the
gray vertical line shows your 50
increase and the black vertical line
shows you're doubling in gene expression
so there you have a lot of the normal
suspects the trem 2 the taro bp and so
forth
which are coming out as highly expressed
when the microglia is touching apart
compared to the microglial cells that
are neighboring but not actually
touching the plaque
um you can see that there are also some
genes that are up in the immediately
neighboring region compared to the
glycogen but not nearly as many
on the right hand side we have the very
same sort of data but this is when we
have the nlf mice with the trem2
mutation and you can see that nearly all
of that up regulation at the plaque is
lost
and down at the bottom there you can
hardly see the writing probably but
those little red that little red writing
down the bottom is all those those um
genes that were so strongly up regulated
in the nlf mice are way down there with
almost no difference and certainly no
statistically significant difference
between them so the trem2 mutation is
completely preventing this very plaque
specific upregulation of the of all of
these genes
we also looked at astrocytes for the
sake of time i'm not going to go um go
into a lot about the astrocytes but
we're getting some very interesting data
to there so this is just plaque and away
for the nlf mice and you can see that
near the plaque there are quite a lot of
genes up regulated there also
some of those are perhaps surprising
genes that we thought were microglial
and you start to worry that perhaps you
are getting microbial signal there but
actually when you look at the literature
you find that quite a lot of these genes
are quite upregulated especially in aged
mice
so for example let's look at the c1qa
there when you look at the ben barris
database um which is this this brain
rnaseq.org
he quotes the the mouse astrocyte ageing
data from clark adele and you can see
that at two years in the hippocampus the
c1qa is well and truly up regulated
counts are still low but it is a lot
more than it is earlier in
earlier in development
and if you look at the full data for the
c12a this is what it looks like and you
can see that the
assets it's
almost doubled in the near to plaque
region
compared to the far from plaque region
and that was rather different from what
we saw in the microglia which were
largely right at the touching plaque
area that it was up regulated
and again trim two completely stops this
this change
and you can see that the far from plaque
area is very very similar to what you
get in wild types and trim two mice so
this is um this is another case where an
interesting piece of information comes
out that we weren't expecting um once
you do things in a cell specific and
regional specific way
just an area a little level of caution i
have kept saying that they are cell
enriched rather than absolutely single
cell this is an interesting result i
think
in the microglial data we get this gene
map2 which is very clearly a neuronal
gene it's not a microglial gene and
however where we have our where we're
taking our sections there are a lot of
dendrites it's a very very full of
synapses um and the microglia and
astrocytes are in around the dendrites
and the synapses and so as dendrites are
such fine structures they probably do
run in and around the microglia and
you're able here to see the effect on
map two of being close to a plaque and
away from the plaque in this uh in this
way
and so it's quite a dramatic uh dramatic
difference there where you have really
down strongly down regulated the map two
expressions possibly because you've
actually lost synapses there map2 is
expressed actually out in the dendrites
so it's an unusual one to pick up you
know mostly most of the rna will be
picked up in the cell body whereas map2
is expressed out in synapses so this
very likely reflects a loss of synapses
um
right right in and around
the plaque so it'll be very interesting
to do similar experiments uh labeling
the neurons instead of labeling the
microglia or the uh or the
the astrocytes
just finally for those who are gene
expression people just to say that the
software from nanostrings actually has
quite a lot of other sorts of things
that you can do
with them i'm no expert in this but i
just thought i would add that there's
quite a lot of other different
types of analysis that are in their
software package that you then have
access to
when you
finish
when you have
done this gene expression analysis
so i think this is going to be a very
powerful technique i'm very excited
about it we certainly are
applying for money to do a lot more we
are
doubling the data the
data set for this particular analysis
and i think very soon we'll have some
really some very quite quite definitive
data both about these dam genes which we
weren't so it's not so surprising that
there's interesting data for them but
some other very interesting things are
also coming out of these data sets
okay thank you very much